I just want to let y'all know
that I'm done doing what I've been
doing from here on everything going to
be
different so you thinking me and you
good now like I said Kanan we got a lot
to talk
about I don't take nothing from her no
more trying to make my own money man
give her one more shot to make it right
between y'all hell no mudy
everybody got their hustle we just got
to find
dogs sound is real dangerous right now
kayen you working for Nick I work for
me that's what you don't understand and
this ain't about what you did it's about
who you
are I need somebody I can count
on thank
is I ain't shooting my way out of
problems no more I
disagree Rebel of the street corner pull
out the Poli got me under pressure when
you're going to get older you're going
to understand why I did what I did I'm
never going to understand none of this
I'm damn sure never will understand
you business is boming you changing the
game I used to wake up everyone and see
my CL on the Block every day a planning
had us running from you done out of
business you don't decide but I'm done
to the project some
one some people BN to be doctors lawyers
ball players I'm here to move weight so
what I do is who I
[Music]
am
fore
[Music]
spe
fore spee
[Music]
spee
[Applause]
goodness just pull over just drop me on
the side of the street I won't say
anything I won't say anything
[Applause]
[Music]
no love you both of
you
Jes who's
this it's me somebody's killing
us
someone's
[Music]
coming Joe what are you not telling
me long before we
met I did bad
things we're in
danger the kids I'm going to fix
this why did you contact me to warn you
need to find that and you trust her
we're going to be dealing with some very
serious people this is going to be
fun doesn't matter what you
do what you
[Music]
say you can't outrun
us if we fight we die if we run we
die most things in this world way more
scared of you than you are of them
because we're apex
predators coffee I'd like a coffee do
you want a
coffee don't really understand how I
ended up
here dashing
around losing sight of myself in the
process you know I think that's been the
story of my my whole
life I'm afraid your
majesty interest in the princess's
private life is unlikely to die down
anytime soon the Press are on our Tails
constantly all one wants is for that
girl to find
[Music]
peace
mommy you okay
I'm
okay it's
just it has all been a bit mad
recently you finally succeeded in
turning this house upside
down it's nothing less than
Revolution that's never mind
set against a background of raar emotion
the royal family remains silent what do
people want from
me for you to be mother to the
nation you've seen the images on the
television Dina gave people what they
needed all over the world in their
thousands and they adored her for
it this is going to be the biggest thing
that any of us has ever
[Music]
seen you've been carjacked right don't
turn around this won't take
long wait who are you someone who
prefers not getting
involved you refer to the special
investigators as your team your soldiers
even your friends you can do not mess
with the special
investigator and now they're all in
trouble
[Music]
they were tortured they dumped them from
a helicopter and they're coming after
us
[Music]
good damn rer we were kids we just wrote
our names in it why'd you got to hit him
so
hard I don't hit
soft what are our
directors have we prepared we
investigate we put bad guys in jail what
does he think he's going to
do just like the good old days yeah you
on the sidelines while I do all the
work he's a boss and bosses give
orders but they took a run at us in
broad
daylight they getting
desperate guys got good instincts guys
got good
everything surveillance photos don't do
you
[Music]
justice looks like you had a rough night
had
worse need a new jacket what's wrong
with the one you just bought it has
blood on
it
pereus that's me mhm that's who you're
named after because he was a hero
because cuz he was Brave and kind and
Against All Odds he managed to find his
way to a happy
ending I'm used to the world feeling
weird to
me like a puzzle with half their own
pieces but lately it all feels different
somehow Percy you are special when
you're ready to hear what the gods have
in store for you they'll tell you Percy
the stories I have told you about great
Gods and
Monsters they are
real this is crazy you are a half blood
and half Bloods are not safe in the
world everything has been training for
what's still ahead of
you hold
on Percy Jackson your father needs your
help the master the Bol has been stolen
if you don't return the boat there will
be war
that is your
quest I know it sounds
daunting but you won't be alone a quest
is always undertaken by three demig Gods
process reality differently we got to
figure out what you're good
at should I try again no
no there's no place for me
here you still don't get where you fit
into all
this we were sent on a quest by the gods
would you think it'll be easy demig Gods
welcome I'm not leaving you perus hold
fast Brave the
storm maybe I won't even need a
sword
[Music]
I'm going to need a
sword
[Applause]
[Music]
fore
inter
[Applause]
[Music]
we have tried everything
you are the only one who gave us hope I
will try my
best been trying to get an angle on this
medical piece Palo macini who's
developing artificial organs medical
Miracles the work I do this could change
the world I take a 3D printed trachea
and transform it into a living organ
this is groundbreaking work the
implications are historic perhaps you'll
even bring the Nobel
home I'm producing a special about you
your patience they really trust
[Music]
you do you trust
me where is
[Music]
he just sicker than any of us he
wasn't why are you not holding him
accountable the issues are completely
unrelated to my procedure you've always
had great instincts maybe you should
trust
them I need you to look into someone for
me he's experimenting on
people I want to see it with my own
eyes my team and I have to deal with
very extreme
cases just the ones extreme enough that
nobody will notice when you kill
them history is built on lines that we
must be willing to
cross what' you do follow what did you
do to them we have to figure out a way
to stop this
guy she's sitting there with a bloody
time bomb in her
throat
clear welcome
back well we are in fact here to study
our next Heist
the biggest and most prestigious auction
house in
Paris across the street lives Miss poac
director of the auction
house man this will give us direct
access to the auction house what we want
is to follow the catacombs of Paris you
know
we can have a lot of
phone I'm man last night I met
someone
[Music]
way
theist Pack's wife why do you dwell on
these Minor
[Music]
[Applause]
Details what have you got a heist we're
going to have such a good time
[Music]
Raquel Mar
elisia my dear Spanish friends pulled a
magnificent job with undeniable
Panache who would want convenient love
going in all or
nothing we Spanish just can't
resist a good
party the only thing that matters is
that the C down has
[Music]
begun